Welcome to the mini-project on data sets and questions.
This is where you're going to get your hands on the Enron data for
the first time, and this is going to serve as sort of the backbone for
the rest of the class.
We want you to get good and familiar with it.
I think this is a really fun lesson because this is where you get to go in and
actually figure out who were all the players, how much money were they making,
who was sending emails to who, stuff like this.
So in this mini-project, I'll provide you with the data set and
then ask you a series of questions that help guide you through how to
navigate through the data set and extract some of the information.